what I'm doing is I'm adjusting the  mechanism and adjusting the tone quality  to get absolutely the best out of the  the piano and these pianos are  incredibly sensitive to having  absolutely everything perfectly adjusted  all the Hammers exactly the correct  distance from the strings all they're  all escaping their correct distance from  the strings all the repetition Springs  with exactly the same amount of power  each note sounding totally exactly like  its neighbor not too bright not too  aggressive but still with plenty of  color all those things so that's it  those that that's a whole level of  refinement that's what I'm here doing  this these notes here's what I've got  mark to a little bit dull so the felt is  relaxed a little bit so we're just going  to take a tiny little whisk her off the  outside just to brighten these notes you  bring them to sound more like their  neighbors  [Music]  right through the whole spices good you  know  [Music]